You are listening to radio lab radio lab
from w n y.
S. E. N. G. N. P. R. Hey, I'm Jad Abumrad. I'm Robert Krulwich.
This is radiolab, the podcast and uh, we've just finished are in the dark tour,
which is the thing we've been, you know, yammering on about for the last year.
Yeah. And we want it to play for you in this podcast.
One of our favorite stories from that show.
Now this was designed for the eye as well as the ear,
this particular performance. So you will not see the Pilobolus dance theater,
which means you will not see, oh man.
Pretty amazing stuff happening on that stage. Yeah.
Strangely beautiful shadow plays on huge white canvas.
I mean gigantic state.
You could go to the website and you can see pictures@radiolab.org yeah,
these guys are really, they're magicians. They do. Yeah, they really are.
We should also note that this story was scored live by the amazing Talwin with
Jason. Slow to on the drums.
Jamie Ryota on the base and it was recorded massively at UCLA is Royce Hall by
Reverend John Delore. So here it is. So for our final segment,
we were thinking through this show,
we thought you knew who would have a really interesting perspective on darkness.
I'm going to be somebody who works in, in a, in a rich dark environment.
Astronauts for example. Yeah. So we called up, uh, NASA,
we talked to an astronaut.
We connected our little studio in New York to their studio DC to talk to an
astronaut. But he was a little late. And here's the funny thing,
when you are on hold with NASA, this is literally what you hear.
[inaudible] sends a blast off feel to yeah.
[inaudible] this is amazing.
This by the way, is literally the case.
You dial one 800 Nash or whatever and they, this is like go to the moon music.
Okay. Hello?
Hello? Hello?
I hear someone breathing mean humor. Yeah, it's probably I'm breathing.
That's the interesting way to meet. So this is our guy. Uh,
Dave Wolf is his name. He's a NASA astronaut.
Have been since 1990 over 20 years. He wasn't really sure why we had called him.
What, what's our topic here? So we explained to him that, you know,
we're doing this show called in the dark. Uh,
we're going to do it on stage in front of some very nice folks. Uh,
do you have any stories that relate in right off the bat? He says,
you've triggered an interesting darkness story. I have. Well,
that's why we calling you up. Yeah. Okay. You're,
you're taping and you're ready. Yep.
Darkness is an interesting theme in space because there's nowhere where the
contrast between light and dark is any more extreme.
Dave has done dozens of spacewalks and he says there have been times when he's
just sort of out there floating in space next to the craft and maybe the a,
the ship tilts a little bit and the wing blocks light that's coming from the sun
or the moon and it creates a shadow and he says the darkness of that shadow is
black or that any black you thought it could be out there in space,
the shadow has no light in it. There's not reflected light from dust in the air.
The earth around you are clouds. It's just pure,
absolute dark.
And you can reach into a shadow, so deep,
so black that your arm can appear to disappear.
[inaudible]
wow. Right in front of your face.
Your head is in the bright light and your arm is in his depths of darkness and
she's gone. Like it's been cut off. Yeah.
[inaudible]
but I do want to tell you a, um,
an experience I had in my first space walk late 97 I had this experience.
Okay. It was from a Russian spacecraft.
You might remember the mirror. Yeah, sure. Space. Craft.
So Dave is up there.
He was with two Russian cosmonauts and he and Anatoly Solovyev,
they were suited up and getting ready to make their first walk into space or his
first walk.
And we did all the preparations to get the suits ready and we're in the air lock
and
door open and they floated out, we
clip dark tethers on outside.
He and Anatoly gently float to the work site and it was dark out and dark up in
space means you're on the night side of the earth in the shadow of the earth.
And her were no external lights on this spacecraft.
This was really, really dark and we were over the ocean and at night.
That basically means you don't see the earth
[inaudible].
You don't see it at all. Not at all. When it's a a moonless night,
you don't see the earth. In fact,
all it might look like to you is the absence of stars.
[inaudible].
Now, I want you to imagine this with me.
He's up there in this darkness in the earth with all of us on it, somewhere far,
far below him. You can't see it and all the while,
and this is really important for what happens next.
He is shooting through space.
He's rocketing across the dark shadow of the earth at five miles a second.
That is 16 times the speed that we're all moving right now because we are on the
earth. But he says at that moment he didn't feel any of that.
It just felt like he was suspended in this cocoon of black floating gently.
He thought, all right, no problem. This is kind of peaceful.
It was just me and the spacecraft and blackness
and suddenly
this one
blazing blight blasts and from below, what was it?
It was the sunrise, you know,
because he and the ship are moving so quickly at the sunrise,
which normally happens here on earth very, very slowly,
calmly at that speed up there,
the sun comes screaming from the eastern edge of the earth straight across the
earth, lights up, everything is seconds and the earth lights up below me.
Suddenly I can look down 200 miles and see that we're moving at five miles per
second. Oceans whooshing clouds, deserts, Roche. He's like, man,
I clutched onto these handrails like there's no tomorrow white knuckled in my
space,
suit gloves because I suddenly had this enormous sense of height and speed.
He says,
it was sorta like if you're standing comfortably on the ground and then some,
someone just flips on the lights suddenly and you realize,
actually I'm not on the ground. I am on a 400,000 foot ladder.
Crazy. You're still in that sunrise moment.
The temperature all also increases by upwards of 400 degrees in the moment.
In the moment. Really this is the most extreme thing I've ever heard.
Are you air conditioned or, or whatever you, you are.
We are totally dependent on that space suit.
But the colors,
what you're seeing on that earth is so spectacular.
The Greens and Blues and the delicate pastel light colors and the contrast and
the brights are just, uh, are present in a,
in anything I've ever seen other than up in space.
Dave and his Russian buddy and a totally,
they're out there for hours doing repairs on the ships. So they are
cause of their speed.
They're going in and out and in and out of these days and nights.
So it's 90 minutes of a light, dark cycle.
So you have 16 nights in 16 days for every Earth Day,
which means as they're working,
this change is happening over and over and over every 45 minutes they go from
blazing light,
two
quiet, dark blazing, light,
[inaudible]
darkness. You can get lost.
You get stories of people doing space walks that lose their orientation or feel
like they're falling.
So he says the only thing to do in that circumstance is just to focus on your
job. Look straight ahead. Only at this group. Only
that this group don't look down and just kind of, Eh, it's,
it's real in this business.
Okay.
So we would in perfectly happy to
end the story right here cause Dave and Anatoly finished their repairs.
Job Well done. They get ready to come back into the spacecraft.
But we cannot not tell you what happens next. This,
this first with a very different kind of darkness. Yeah.
So the two of them pull themselves by their tethers to come back into the air
lock to go back in. But when it was time to come back in,
they couldn't get back in. You were locked out of your spaceship,
you could call it locked out. We were trapped outside. Yes.
Essentially their air lock was busted that they couldn't repressurize it.
And if he can't get it at the right pressure, you can't reenter them. No.
And we worked on it for four or five hours and ran out our resources and ran out
of oxygen or what, we have plenty of oxygen.
It turns out that what you run out of first is your carbon dioxide scrubbing a
unit that takes the co two out of your suit.
And now the problem with this one is usually in a space accident you figure it
only hurt for a moment,
but when you die of CO2 intoxication,
that drags out. That's not had that. So I have some miserable way to go.
What does, what does he mean? Did you ever play that up?
What happens is first you get a headache
and then your muscles start to twitch.
Eventually your heartbeat starts to accelerate faster, faster, faster.
You go into convulsions and then you die.
Luckily the life support system has an extra cartridge that gave us an extra six
or so hours. We used all that and uh,
trying to fix the hatch and we couldn't get it to hold air and,
uh, we were done. Did you know you are done? I mean you, yeah, yeah,
pretty much. And Annie had done like in over,
yeah. Yeah. No more ideas
done like in dead.
So they decided, okay, we've got to do something. Last ditch maneuver.
If we can't get our usual airlock to work, maybe we can make a new one.
Because see on the Mir space station,
it's this big cylinder with these rectangular modules that jut out and one of
those modules is the airlock. But there are these adjacent ones,
which are normally just living quarters. They thought,
well if we can't get our usual airlock to pressurize the right, you know,
pressure, maybe we can go to the next one over and try and pressurize it.
Essentially treating that next module and as a air lock.
And we open the hatch into that next module.
And in order to though to go into it,
we had to disconnect our umbilicals cause you can't close the hatch over your
umbilical. Right.
I mean umbilical was providing our cooling to our suits.
So as soon as we disconnected, well that gives you maybe five,
eight minutes at Max before you, before you what?
I don't even want talk about it. It's so bad. Did you, did you look down that?
Yeah. Look this one up too.
Essentially what happens is you boil inside your space, you in a very ugly way.
So Dave and I totally think, okay,
we've got to get through this tiny hatch and into this room and they've got to
do it fast. But they also know if you struggle hard and go too fast,
you'll never get much time at all in that suit before that heat builds up on
you. So he thinks, okay, hurry, hurry. But slowly Stallone,
what I did not anticipate was as soon as we disconnected our umbilicals that
Pfizer would fog up and you'd now be having to feel your way of lined.
Yeah,
you could spit and kind of get a little area through the fog.
So I'm in the air lock trying to make my way into the next section and I was
crawling along the wall moving into the next section and I spit on my visor,
you know, to make a little hole to look through and get a hit.
And it was an area I had been sleeping in some weeks before.
And I had left picture of my family taped with Scotch tape on the wall and I
spit out an adviser and I, my helmet light went there.
And there was this picture of my family
right here in this moment as I was scooting across the wall and in what was
likely my last minutes.
So this is how it's gonna end. So this is it.
And then look, it's so strange. There they are.
But I look back at that and I, her now of course,
Dave and his partner made it back into the space station. Barely.
But it didn't strike me really till months later on the earth.
Uh, how, how, how close Saturday Ben. And uh,
what a strange situation this Russian guy must be your best friend.
Like,
like he could probably get call each other and say it 20 years later you go,
well,
not many people been through anything like that together and are there to talk
about it. And you just reminded me of something.
So we're going to leave you with one last story from Dave.
He was kind of a story machine. This is from that same stay in space,
involves same friend and a totally,
they were out there doing some work on the ship, you know,
floating in space again.
And then mission control radios in tells them to pause for a while.
We had a period where we had to wait through the night to go on with our work.
So he says, Look, David at [inaudible] on Russian,
of course I wanted to show you something and we cooked our tethers on,
pushed ourselves about six feet away.
We're weighed about six feet a tether so that our eyes couldn't see anything but
out in space. And I, I,
I turned my air conditioner down a little, you know,
so it was kind of warm and I was floating in this spacesuit just looking out in
the dark, the blackness of space and
yeah,
I felt like I didn't have a space suit on. It was so comfortable.
The air temperature was just right.
I felt like I was just out any universe
in the stars.
I couldn't see anything but stars all around me and I couldn't feel anything
outside of spacecraft going five miles per second out in the universe.
Was that what he wanted to show you? Yeah, I think so.
This is his rocking chair on the front porch thing that were hammock almost.
He didn't want to talk. He said, let's just be quiet.
Turn your helmet light off so you don't get any reflected light. Yes.
Uh, uh, relax. Russ slobber violet
[inaudible] [inaudible] you relax. Relax.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
now had you been there in the theater?
This is the moment where we gave everybody a little pinpoint of light.
A little hand carried star.
They could put over their heads and wave together like 2000 tiny little lights
from the seats. Okay. Can it be of stars? We saw this happen again and again,
like 18 times. I think we performed this every time.
It was just like breathtaking. Yeah.
[inaudible]
this whole show came together.
Thanks to so many people onstage and off and we want to make a couple of thank
yous before we go. Very, very special things to make bowls.
Who found our astronauts. He found Dave wealth. Yeah.
Also to Pilobolus the dance company and to the Palabra law. Yes.
Starting with Itamar, cu bovie lily bins, Matt Kent, Nay Jaworski, Greg Laffy.
Yes. And the dancer. Chris Whitney of Rhetto, Anthony Olivar, Christina conjure,
Evan Adler, Anika Sheaf, and the Olvera twins. Edwin and Roberto.
We love you guys. Yeah. Demitri Martin,
thank you so much for coming and you know, creating the show with us.
Tau Win and Jason [inaudible], thank you so much to them. And Mike Faba,
Jake fines arena one, John Valore, Alyssa Lacasse, fully Nick Nisa, Foro,
Kaitlin Fitzwater, Rebecca Lehrer, and Roslyn Lutein, loots boots, most of all,
most, most,
most of all to Alan Horn who loved doing this and made it so fun to do.